foreign
[Music]
times
when we're doing the technique we stick
with the centrifugal energy on the
homologous side
at this time I'm going to make one more
spiral
inside his spiral okay that's the key so
it's not all that different when uh
replicas okay and he starts pressing on
me and I'll make a spiral inside his
spiral to do what I want to do
same thing here
I'll slow it down
okay
so he's gonna come around
here's where normal is
but I'm gonna not step there
I'm going to do my triangle step
here
[Music]
why should I do that
out boom in
so he doesn't change his pattern but I
change my throwing forward
okay
there's things you can do that help you
out a little bit
so
one is
this step
go out behind him
okay this way
this way then you're going to be inside
but it's not necessary
you could do the same exact
throwing geometry this way you see do
you bring it here and then in you go
okay
another way to think about it is it's
the same
edema angle
you see do you recognize his front
inward kazushi
got it
so you're doing this y'all
boom there's this
face displacement
so watch that now
there it is do you see and in I go
okay that's your opinion
let's try
okay I'm not
I'm not of the earlier kaitan knob is
that I was young like this one
you see
oftentimes
I stop the motion
you see that
and he's based
do you understand you know I'm already
close
you know I can't get that foot in there
you'll see a lot of people will do small
edeming
can you see that you can't get the
footage
foreign
this way
[Music]
but I'm basically just pushing it
do you understand
so
if he's strong
okay there's no mechanical advantage
there
so
what I'm doing here
is use EDD me
on his arm
do you see that
so are you going to come in
and then
push that arm over okay so uh
if you don't mind
you can keep your base if you want
and you just grab the wrist
and I control the head
and we're just gonna pull against the
lack of slack into shoulder mechanism
resist
keep pulling
he's gonna go over okay
to that we add the centrifugal energy
and the it's inward spiraling kazushi
okay
so when I watch your Technique is you
don't know how to lock out
the shoulder mechanism
here
okay
you're going this way
feel the tension
that's where I can't take it anymore
that's what I move
boom
you got it don't don't go where they're
Slack
go where there's no slap then it will be
a lever on this road
this
see that okay let's try it
don't over rely on the arm mechanisms
your Technique is really here
on the edema
you want a redundant throwing system
okay so here I'm ensuring
just like Egypt
I'm not going to crank his arm when I'm
here like this I I enter you understand
just like juji nugget oh no I'm here no
I'm gonna attack the leg here this way
I'm not attacking his arm I'm not
attacking his arms I'm attacking his
face right here
you understand
[Music]
so don't be out here
you need to be you need to attack that
hit
boom
[Music]
hit in deep
feel it and feel him load his koshy
boom this way
deep in okay try it again
[Music]
foreign
he's not directly under me do you see
that if he does land under you
you see you're here like this this leg
you can either stop here I'm going to
first kick him in the mastoid so you're
gonna go boom and then fly him down on
the stomp okay so he might grab he might
come around grab your hand you're not
grabbing your leg anymore you understand
and then you'll walk out pull in another
Stomp and you're out of there okay but
you should have a projection
understanding of what you're trying to
do okay try to